c'est le retour du froid et par voie de
conséquence de la neige qui a réapparu
sur les pyrénées si janvier est
traditionnellement un mois creux après
les fêtes c'est un moment choisi aussi
pour aller skier s'il vous reste encore
quelques jours de vacances à prendre
parmi les stations les plus prisés par
les aquitains en dehors du berne
il y a le complexe de barèges la mongie
c'est sur les contreforts du pic du midi
que se situe le plus grand domaine
skiable des pyrénées françaises de part
et d'autre du col du tourmalet barèges
la mongie regroupe 52 remontées
mécaniques et plus de 100 km de pistes
balisées côté barrage pour cette saison
86 87 les parkings ont été agrandis le
débit a été augmenté de 400 ce qui rend
leur sur le télésiège decobert et de 300
skieurs à l'heure sur le télécabine de
la laquette cet hiver barre elle jouera
la carte de la nouveauté avec une large
place réservée aux nouveaux skis et aux
sports d'hiver le mousse qui le cercle
sous le skimboard ou encore le parapente
le deltaplane
mais le confort du skieur et surtout son
accueil restera la priorité des
priorités
nous allons essayer d'offrir aux skieurs
la meilleure prestation possible
nous avons déjà passé tout le personnel
de la station un stage accueille 80
personnes ont appris à se comporter avec
le skieur pour lui donner le meilleur
confort
nous allons aussi inaugurer le damage de
nuit passée de 2 heures de la marche par
jour ou plutôt de travail de la neige à
8 heures de travail de neige par machine
et puis barèges fait cet hiver un beau
cadeau pyrénées puisque allart et ouvre
son tremplin de saut à 90 m il sera le
seul existant sur la chaîne côté la mort
j malgré neuf mille six cents lits au
pied des pistes priorité encore cette
année à l'immobilier mais un impératif
le respect du site et l'entretien des
pistes la municipalité de bagnères est
en train d'étudier une révision de
plan d'occupation des sols avec comme
volonté d'accroître les possibilités
d'hébergement de façon à ce que nous
ayons une meilleure relation entre les
énormes possibilités de remontées
mécaniques plus de trente mille
personnes meurent et populaire d'une
population plus élargie de la station la
magie c'est déjà si vous voulez un petit
village
il faut que ça devienne quelque chose de
plus important encore belge plus la
magie égale le plus grand domaine
skiable des pyrénées françaises
mais attention à condition de rester
ensemble